hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights of [ __ ]
boys sooo time for shop number two as
well
delicious sweet amber of the Gods I I
don't know why I filled it up more than
last time I already know that this is a
bigger shot than the last one
okay it's early in the night cheers
everybody you guys are awesome but I
love you a lot thank you for supporting
me and what I do oh I'm gonna get so
white-girl wasted it's awesome no game
so I probably could keep bashing my head
against this guy and possibly win at one
point but for now it's gonna be like I
just need to like do other stuff because
I've had a real Mike did you find to be
cool okay so honest truth just being
totally transparent I didn't find out
what I was supposed to do in the in the
meantime in between because I forgot
that I was supposed to do that and I
wanted to get to my shot so I kind of
just rolled right into the second
episode here because I love you and
whatnot but also this worked out
fantastically this works out amazingly
I'm so happy that this happened so now I
can just smash this hat into oblivion
[Laughter]
inhale my dog huh balloon boy
what is the ops oh I know exactly what
the UPS is I don't need a weapon that's
for damn sure
you have a esoteric sex toy that maybe
maybe would be useful for a foxy foxy
not lady but machine a foxy lady machine
is mangle like a girl or a guy was that
ever determined like not that any of the
animatronics actually have gender but I
know that the Internet has raged debated
about it for a long time like I know
mangle has like makeup and lipstick in
one night in his pink that is a pink bow
or whatever but that doesn't necessarily
mean these girl or she's girl I don't
know like I don't know if there's any
kin of that if I'm just opening up a can
of worms I shouldn't open up
but either way like you know curiosity I
guess that's why everyone else was
curious okay maybe the way to define I'm
just gonna buy all this [ __ ] Freddy here
cuz I got none of my other bros here oh
this is so beautiful
like this turned out great so now I can
like destroy anybody in the early level
area so I guess I can go back to Fox's
room and try to beat the hat in there
which would allow me to do what I need
to do in order to do something yep that
made sense
so because maybe this one the balloon
boy in here would have what I need
boy girl that kills you yeah all right
how you doing
what does the UPS indeed inhale and I
don I need a special something you don't
have a special something but I need a
special something
damn it's where am I gonna get a special
something do you have like a story you
have a street boy you have a sport I'm
okay they don't have a sex toy I'm
pretty sure they don't have a sale but
maybe maybe I don't think I might as
well buy extra stuff okay so if I can
just put on these parts here optimized
oh no I need to heal up real badly okay
there we go so I don't know where I'm
gonna find an esoteric sex toy is that
oh maybe in the bathroom somewhere
because they didn't really explore all
the curtains of the bathroom I know you
needed I know I know I'm angle you need
oh I know you need it I know you needed
I know okay is it done done and done
okay all right cool all right we're good
we're gonna now okay so I'm gonna go
home I'm a big go in the bathroom and
see if I can find something else also I
might start killing some of the cameras
because I know that I can beat him now
way too much damage
haha lots and lots of damage pop miss me
lots and rocks with damage okay so now
that that's done and gone I really do
think that that golden Freddy incidents
was like extremely rare like obscenely
rare I'm just an unlucky [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] this place is like right kill
this guy Wow
haha gods [ __ ] ah that was barely worth
it but I get to level 11 anyway so we're
on my brews we're all my bros and this
my bros dang it
why am i all braless okay there anyway
I'm going here hail fragile your future
what up big baby lamb and then blam
okay oh man those big shots those extra
shots they hit you hard after just a
little bit of time he said there's got
to be like something else here maybe I
can just beat this camera see what else
I can do - yeah that's a level - okay no
such luck on this one cuz I really don't
know if there was like well uh what am I
supposed to press there's no instruction
I press space and it got out of it
alright whatever there's got to be
something there's got to be there's got
to be something there because one -
purple one yellow one green it's gotta
be something there hey I'm gonna figure
this out BRB wait is this it
I'm literally just holding down the down
arrow and it's slamming a cake into that
kid's face it looks like something very
different and very wrong but I'm not
gonna say it everyone else can say it
for me okay so I guess maybe might might
might my ID here's that I beat the
middle game by allowing by seducing the
purple guy so somehow I can have the
patience to beat this game and then go
back to the third one with foxy and do
that one maybe I can win something
Oh I'll BRB this is a massive waste of
my time isn't it I'm just gonna go ahead
and call it like I am absolutely wasting
my time slamming a cake into a child's
face great I'm gonna go ahead and call
this that this is stupid and I shouldn't
be doing this
oh my god I did it okay cool alright
I did it great okay
I know but I did it it said that I did
it so if I do it for the other one then
it's gonna work right right okay okay
all right cool all right so now I just
gotta beat this one and this one I
believe that I'm pressing it I should be
holding it down okay
it's mighty that's my guess anyway yeah
Oh see that was it I needed to hold it
down but I immediately turned back and
did the down arrow so I don't need to do
that I get this okay I got it I'm gonna
get it okay okay okay all right okay get
down oh man no slow e whoa huh there's
gonna be like a trap here it's gonna box
me in where it shouldn't be I know it is
[ __ ] go down go up whoa whoa whoa why
are you doing what are you doing what
you holy [ __ ] okay focusing focusing all
of my power I'm using the force I've
turned off my targeting computer
everyone's gonna die because I turned
off my targeting computer on the most
important mission that the rebels have
ever done and everyone's gonna die on
the rebel base and I'm never gonna be
able to kiss my sister Oh Star Wars I
did all of them I technically did all of
them I technically did all of them and
technically doing it is good so did I do
something
but I did them all
maybe I got to do it all like the same
time that I'm here so let me do this one
again okay okay cool cool cool I did it
okay
was there no point to any of that are
you know I'm gonna look up walk through
because I still don't know what I'm
supposed to be doing so I'm okay I'm
back I figured this out well I didn't
figure it out I looked up a walkthrough
but that's the equivalent figurine now
but it's actually pretty silly okay I
didn't look at much else but I need to
do is I need to Freddie's fragile and
masculinity by okay okay
Oh God this harness [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
doc not chica got one damn it it's hard
to control it may look easy but this is
very hard to control [ __ ]
god this is really hard to control it's
it's like Fox you have to hold down and
I have to hold down the thing
hey blue boy oh this is a heavy discount
[Music]
ok cool foam cupcake a everything
already have that or I can get that
elsewhere not here ok cool
alright so I got oh I didn't get the
cupcake house but oh she's gonna toss me
back down isn't she
ok the return of my ex
okay okay all right cool there was no
way that I would have been able to do
that without exactly what I had in mind
for me before great okay
you're lost Soviets were repaid damn it
it's so difficult so I need to get 30 of
these [ __ ] dammit stop missing them you
son of a [ __ ] it's really hard to come
you [ __ ] this is really aa piece of [ __ ]
god damn is so hard not really but you
know what I mean oh god did I get 30
probably not okay now I got him thank
you thank you
I got him she's at least I had my tokens
from before now that your godless winged
hell spawn thanks
yes bound ok what's the [ __ ] I don't
know but at least I got what I need and
at least I don't know cool things have
happened
I was cop-con disappointed that I'm not
the semi shattered masculinity toy
Freddy okay so what I need to do is I
need to okay so do I have I probably
have enough okay so I got I had some of
my old equipment that I gave to chica
there and now I'm good so now I just
need to figure out what the hell I need
to do for the other ones and then I'll
be good I'll try to consult the
walkthrough as little as possible such
that I can still retain some of my pride
as if that's a thing that needs to be
retained okay why does she cannot have
any stat skill I don't know
I think I need to level her up okay so
since I am more powerful now at least I
should be able to do a level 2 area okay
geez level 3 okay so what I need to do
is I need to level up toy chica and then
I also need to
do I need to do like what do I need to
do seriously what do I need to do here I
don't know how to get a sex boy for
manga and there's got to be a way to get
Bonnie there's got to be a way to get
Bonnie that I'm not understanding right
now what what okay cool cool cool cool
okay was that the smut Oh what was that
you're supposed to be a random drop from
a higher what maybe I got a drop this
off at the other one in mangles office
that doesn't make any sense if it was
gonna be that easy why didn't I just why
didn't I get it already I've been
fighting a lot of those things okay
maybe I need to fight like the level two
enemies I'm really confused on now I
guess I'm moving the story forward by
not even trying anymore I really didn't
know like why that worked okay whatever
fine fine by me I ain't gonna complain
all right so wait skills
torchy good okay so I guess she good I
guess it's only done by tech and not
necessarily by anything else
okay I see you our possession of the
thing I must say I will offer the erotic
toy same for the paper token yes please
please yes now then I don't want
anything out from you you weirdo
that's hoy
indeed I do what was that running is
that the normal foxy where did he go
what am I supposed to be doing okay
alright fine fine then fine I guess I
got to go find oxy now somehow I can
meet you guys right okay alright this is
easy god I got it so now I gotta go find
foxy the normal foxy who decided to take
a giant dragon dildo I'm assuming for
some reason I'm gonna need a lot more
pizzas geez I guess maybe I don't know
if I'm gonna be able to take a ride down
I should have bought more pizzas while I
was down there but I didn't think about
it because I didn't think that I let's
focus on getting the cupcake that I
didn't think I could have gotten
discount pizzas Abadie the way I know
that I'm gonna replace them with larger
pizzas later on anyway hey foxy how you
doing you don't sound so good foxy you
know oh this is gonna be as hard as the
other one work I don't know
okay maybe not that didn't hurt that
much damn assuming this is gonna be only
as hard as anything else was saying
there's gonna be well [ __ ] alright maybe
not okay
goddamnit thank goodness I found the
real Mike because if I hadn't done that
there's no way I would be able to do
these things that I need to do not the
sex-toy back I'm so sick of this
[ __ ] me too Freddie
I'm so sick of it okay so I need to heal
up you and I need to get a resurrection
device for chica but battle is half away
til later because right now I'm in the
middle of something [ __ ] weirdos in
their [ __ ] sheets
here's your dildo oh okay so now I got
three party members and nothing else to
show for it probably god damnit I was
right there thank you okay I just need
to get I'm gonna any God I need a lot
more tokens I mean I know I'm gonna get
more tokens once I start getting up to
the point where I'm able to get the
things that I need right now it's like
[ __ ] okay so now that those guys are
where they are I can probably beat some
of these cameras now what I can oh yes
please stop that music
[Music]
ready I want to be with the kids you're
not yes you know thank goodness because
Jesus I didn't even notice that at first
but if I had to walk through the entire
game with that [ __ ] going in my ears
I would have been very upset okay John
kill em kill em blam blam okay toy chica
could actually do something dead so now
that I did that I'm gonna have to start
leveling up in a different area but for
now I'm gonna camera I'm gonna [ __ ] all
over this camera oh hey wait that's not
fair why you have skill people see you
guys at AG the streamers they're easy
you can beat him easily done and done
done and done you're done at dad dad dad
dad you done are done there we go
well that was easy holy [ __ ] that was
awesome Oh manga learned electroshock
yes indeed eat your [ __ ] that's what the
camera would definitely want to do okay
so there's three cameras in this room I
can I can definitely beat them all right
probably okay skills do your thing I
don't know what is that not royalty-free
music or something
BAM oh so the electrocution prize
another stunning attack so hopefully
though I am ridiculously lucky for
getting that thing when I needed it I
don't know if like there's an ultimate
weapon in the in the beginning here for
what's-his-face
hi great I find to know that I wouldn't
have done that one until way later okay
but people sat in the last game that I
needed to beat the puppet to get the
Ultima net but I don't need to do that
until I actually get to the point where
I'm able to capably handle him I don't
know what music that is I really hope
that's royalty-free via the sounds
Japanese and whatnot so it's entirely
possible that was
relax Tonino
[Music]
like most things in my life bagging olio
for the best okay I did it okay I did it
cool cool cool cool cool cool cool okay
I [ __ ] DDT to my [ __ ] alright so
anyway I'm doing good friends doing this
fun the game I got really lucky in this
second episode buy tickets cuz I took
another shot and a big one at that
either way thank you again everybody so
much for watching I love you guys do
that thank you for joining me on this
fun adventure hope you guys are loving
the series I know that I'm gonna have a
lot of fun with it so thank you get
everybody and as always I will see you
[Music]